some good news here at noon the family  of a woman who disappeared while  vacationing here in las vegas says she  is safe  aretha finkbacher traveled here from  washington state with her fiance and  friends  late last night her aunt reached out to  our sasha loftis confirming that she has  been found  we just miss her a lot i just hope that  this helps more indigenous people reach  out  and say hey if they can do it we can do  it  the urban indian health institute says  hundreds of indigenous people  are missing across the country aretha's  family is really hoping that the story  inspires other families to never give up  looking for their missing loved ones